that's the weirdest thing about comedy
it can work one night and not the next
and you're like it's the same wording
same delivery yeah
but hey that's comedy
hey here we are in new jersey in the
green room of the stress factory
great club shameless plug and uh it
doesn't help me cause i'm already here
and
show's happening in 10 seconds but uh
yeah
we're gonna try some new jokes try them
out on twitter something's been okay
and then we got two shows tonight so
we'll try it on the first show see what
happens
tweak try it on the second show and if
you want to come back tomorrow that'll
be a couple more shows but hey
i don't know you got kids you're getting
late you're gay i don't know what you
got
going on hold on oh that was a little
sorry doug should be fun that guy's
going to take a wee wee
there you go and uh last night was a hot
show
let's hope for another one friday night
rosh hashanah
jewish new year thanks for the extra
holidays there jews
all right we'll see you out there fires
out you know
as far as outdoor show goes this is one
of the better setups
but i don't know what the hell the
winner is going to bring like in the
bedroom
this is a full hour all new
this is corona only and this is the new
ones i need to try
to get into the alley
hey comedy huh
we're really doing it how do you feel
coming off that show
feels good we're good i tried some new
but uh over
overall
have you ever met your doppelganger no
you guys
are like identical yeah
so we just did a friday early show now
we're doing friday
late show this show friday late show
typically not always typically a little
more tired a little boozier
they've been day drinking or they've
been uh boozing at dinner and then they
come to a 10 o'clock
show this one could be a little dicey
so we'll see what
there we happens i appreciate it i hate
myself
thanks for coming these are weird times
you know let's be honest
i can't believe we're all here because
i'm a guy [ __ ] to bat
schools are closed you know which sucks
for the parents great for me though
because now i can drive by them again
yeah this whole thing's crazy i hate it
what are we six months in now
corona starting to feel like the check
engine light you know
at first it was scary but after a while
you're like [ __ ] it i gotta go to work
the news is a bummer how about that
fouchy he's cute
he's so little he's like a coconut
groundhog you know
hey every time i see him like i only got
six more weeks of pandemics
thanks for coming out i know it's cold
hey good to see you how's that cocaine
there you go that's for her she won't
even
i don't know i'm just so sick of this
stuff you know i'm starting to feel like
a middle eastern woman in a ranged
marriage
right i do what i'm told i cover my face
when i say my opinion i can yell that
my own acid or is
jesus keeps coming up on me like a
[ __ ] douchebag at the
all shore all right back it up is that a
car alarm
that's a real career peak right there
ah yes
show comedy central oh good uh
some hyundai is getting [ __ ]
sports are trying to come back sports
are weird there's nobody in the seats
i'm watching a basketball game the
stands are empty
weird it's eerie i got an idea
all those racist statues we tore down
put them in the seats
right there's going away you're sitting
somewhere hell i think that'll make the
players play better it'll motivate him
like [ __ ] you roberty lee i'm duncan
a minute all right hot crowd this [ __ ]
never works
all right cool hey welcome back sir good
to have you there
sell a couple edibles good to have you
there
should
and let me say this when i wrote those
jokes for you
i should also say he wrote for michael
richards
i gotta say i was way off the second
show was way better they were hot
i mean the new stuff worked the old
stuff worked the ending was good
i estimated wrong i assumed
assumption is the mother of all anal
what is it uh
if you assume you make an ass out of me
and your dad whatever it is but
i was way off and they were hot and i
loved them i love you
i listen to you every [ __ ] van i'll
never stop [ __ ] like wow
you're the one thanks buddy oh thank you
thank you i thought he was a fan i
thought he would give me the food
money brownie no thank you though
yeah thanks for coming it's gonna be a
hot show
who knows i might bomb but hey i was a
cub scout i've been [ __ ] in a tent
before
i bombed the last show but uh don't
worry i was a cub scout and it's in the
first time i've been [ __ ] a tent
here we are jersey saturday night we got
the heat lamps going
that guy's hard yeah
a couple people were just giving me the
[ __ ] the evil eye
you know just like and you want to be
like this does well
normally there's nothing worse than a
crowd going like this guy's not that
good
i'm like it works i swear to god it
works this crowd's like anal it takes a
minute
um eventually i feel good until my
stepdad
i'm not even thinking of my act i'm just
like it's almost like you're floating
just in it it's like you're surfing like
i'm on the wave and tonight i
felt like i was just paddling the whole
time even uh they had to stop the shoot
of batman the batman movie had to be
stopped because
batman got corona which i'm not shocked
by because the wrong part of his face is
covered
what can you do we were talking a little
bit yesterday how like
you're not like a big laugh out loud
kind of guy do you feel like when you're
in an audience do you like if it was an
audience full of you
it would be horrible and i i i'm aware
of that a lot of
a bunch of marks going yes yes
which i get that guy if i'm that guy
other people got to be that guy but
i don't get the anger you know like the
you know it's almost like they're not
happy to be out
and i'm like you came out i didn't make
you do this
once again left side pushing through
come on ready the show is worse if you
suck all right we're getting there the
right side's
you know really hates the mask joe biden
yeah can't smell little girl's hair
you look chilly hang tight sister all
right
you got that i've been molested vibe
that's why you shoot a ball it goes in
the hoop it counts counts on monday
accounts on saturday accounts in india
accounts in africa and counts in america
that joke
killed on friday night both shows
saturday night
nothing that's comedy
five
good mom i wish she was my mom
all right let's go in and drink heavily
is it like necessary now more than ever
to have a camera guy doing comedy
yeah look at this queef over here in the
corner yeah and you guys got a black
queef
i mean you gotta have your guy